in this in this drilling he he is trying
to do his
stuff he's trying to do
it he doesn't have to go full blast he
doesn't have to kill me cuz we're
drilling you get it but he is trying to
do those moves okay so as as I'm
circling around he's still trying to do
he's still trying to get under and get
that thing you see and I'm I'm
toes what you're naaza is
not it's not a cancellation of that it
is works it works because he's doing
that okay so in other words to me this
is different did you see I went in and
then I throw the
guy he's trying to get
me right home he's trying to get me that
energy that's that's what I I want to
deal
with that's what we're
drilling so he goes boom P that energy
so okay what is that what do you have to
do in your
Keyon here there is contestation can you
see oh that has to go through me has to
go through me so emotionally I'm relaxed
[Applause]
home it's not
this you see that
difference so he's going to go Bo pop
Here Comes his weight right there go
back right way when he comes in who this
is where I'm yielding right here fitting
in there loose and relaxed did you feel
the slip it's like a
slip he's going to come in I'm going to
stick to him and no he goes in I slip
right
there slip boom bend the
yel and that's what I use to throw
then the throw is CQ
projection so boom H this is
momentum and that's
so he has his
effort what do you notice he's not doing
your perfect somersault
roll who cares
y won't
po that's not it
okay
boom that was it too